le vice premier ministre et ministre des
finances
dire que ce discours était attendue
serait un euphémisme bestia félin
d'offres un portrait prudent d'une
économie secouée par une crise qui est
loin d'être terminée nous savons ce que
nous devons faire pour passer à travers
les moins sombre cru nous attendent
le déficit fédéral atteint maintenant
les 380 2 milliards de dollars un niveau
historique qui pourrait se creuser
davantage si la crise perdure les
programmes des demeure la priorité du
gouvernement
la subvention pour le loyer commercial
sera prolongé jusqu'en mars tout comme
la subvention salariale qui couvrira
dorénavant jusqu'à 75 % du revenu on
parle de gros montants d'argent on parle
de gros chef pour venir supporter
l'économie
j'oserais dire que c'est la bonne
nouvelle de cette annonce économique
ottawa offre également son aide au monde
du spectacle et au secteur touristique
durement frappée par la crise de l'aide
aussi pour les aéroports et le transport
aérien régional me riait encore pour les
grands transporteurs qui sont toujours
en discussions avec ottawa et beaucoup
de copies qui passeront pas travers j'ai
passé le gouvernement bat sur quelle
planète il vi notant qu'ils pensent que
nous on peut continuer à avis à ce genre
de situation le terrain ont pu être
entrevu carrière pour capter leurs
familles en santé
les familles auront droit à une
bonification temporaire de la location
canadienne aux enfants qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à 1200 $ par enfant de moins
de 6 ans ceux qui se sont vus imposer le
télétravail pourront déduire jusqu'à 400
$ de frais de leur déclaration de
revenus les éléments verte de notre
relance se rend évidemment une important
élément du nantes au pian et si elle
maintient que l'heure n'est pas à la
relance
christian friedel jette les bases d'une
vision résolument verte et offre aux
propriétaires jusqu'à 5000 $
subventions pour des rénovations
écoénergétiques
pour le reste du plan de relance la
ministre des finances prévoit entre 70
et 100 milliards de dollars et promet de
consulter les canadiens
on va prendre l'hiver pour faire le
travail
oui le point monsieur le président il ya
des millions de canadiens qui sont
oubliés par les libéraux pour
l'opposition
l'énoncé économique d'aujourd'hui rate
la cible l'absence de vision quant à la
relance suggère deux choses soit ils ne
savent pas où vivent ou soit il se garde
sopo potentiellement définir la plate
forme d'une fenêtre électorale des
dépenses exceptionnelles pour une crise
exceptionnelle rappelle christian free
run et surtout des dépenses temporaires
et un déficit qui devrait retomber sous
la barre des 25 milliards de dollars 10
5 ans souligne la ministre sans
toutefois offrir de calendrier pour un
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
ici daniel thibault radio canada ottawa